hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time
september 22nd we're going to be in
houston and september 23rd to the 25th
we're going to be in austin for the moon
tower comedy festival ever heard of it
then uh dallas fort worth on september
26th and we're bringing it back up north
baby uh september 30th we're going to be
in long island
and then
what are we doing if we're going home
for cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're going to be
at helium comedy club in philadelphia
get those tickets they're gonna move
fast i'm telling you yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage sure is little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they go to be classy yeah those
are just a big old piece of trash oh
yeah i'm your host dave foley coming at
you on a beautiful day down here in aunt
toddy's basement all is quiet she's down
the casino there not in vegas or the
shore pennsylvania casino yeah she likes
the slots sure who does i think she's uh
mixing and mingling with one of the
security guards over there oh she's
she's got the hots for uh for a guy on
the floor yep so if you see one of those
uh those metal detector wands on the
kitchen table do not be alarmed don't go
upstairs don't go upstairs no if you see
the room rocking don't come knocking my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the ceo of are you garbage
he is the ceo of aru garbage he's the
fall guy basically when the feds come
knocking stroll man baby
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true
true the [ __ ] roof baby it's cooking
and then i would be like i've said many
times it'd be a [ __ ] jerk-off if i
didn't bring up the greatest website of
all time www.page cheers salute to you
patreon.com
you garbage check it out get a [ __ ] ton
of bonus content ayg hard feelings live
streams you know the [ __ ] deal why am
i telling you go check it out you love
it we love it thank you guys so much and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good look good give it
up for t-bone mcmuffin mr toby mcmullen
what's up dudes what up t-bone oh a rare
h-foley stumble on the intro yes sir yes
i'm human after all ladies and gentlemen
you know what i mean i'm not superman
although we do have the same body type
anyway gang we could not be more fatter
than a speeding bullet
i'm fatter than an apartment building
able to eat whole sandwiches in a single
single bite
gang that's neither here nor there i
don't listen to these bozos we got some
star power in the [ __ ] house today we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special old pal here with us
today for the first time she is a very
funny stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster you have seen her on the good
fight crazy ex-girlfriend viral beauty
clash crashing two girls one show my
crazy love deadly affairs uproarious at
midnight night train with wyatt scenic
the mystery hour this week at the comedy
cellar the late show with stephen
colbert ever heard of it i have cbs
we're talking network here baby hassan
minaj adult boy of course you've seen
her on the comedy lineup on netflix and
she has an amazing podcast called inside
the closet that you gotta check out but
the big question about his mind today is
she garbage ladies and gentlemen for the
first time ever we have a guest that is
missing a tube
i never i didn't notice maybe baby
stavros maybe
was missing his tooth when he was on the
pod yeah i uh i know i'm a woman
everybody thank you i i knocked it out
just for the show i wanted to i was
trying to get booked i'm like who do i
got to punch around here to get on are
you garbage method actually trying to
get a high score i didn't know that i
thought that he just had a space in his
teeth i didn't know he was missing a
tooth i'm like oh no he's been missing
he's been missing a tooth for quite
quite a long time yeah okay i guess i
didn't clock it i just got the fake one
that he puts in okay there we go on a
retainer or whatever i want to say as a
friend of yours to defend you please
ladies and gentlemen normally she's not
missing a tooth obviously she's very
well put together takes care of herself
she works out all the time but right now
she's in the middle of a little dental
snafu little dental snap it's gonna be
strike number one unfortunately yeah and
also i lost so i had the temporary tooth
that he had yeah and when i got when i
had the first when it first got like
they knew that i wasn't going to be
without tooth is that what they say
without tooth that's how they say that
what was it because i remember you you
went you got veneers i had veneers six
years ago i got veneers at a place
called harlem dental and the place was
great people are like did you get bad
veneers no the place was great he did
let me pay cash and come in at weird
hours and get a steep discount so maybe
jesus
so i got i got the veneers there but
they started popping out this summer and
then
you still have them are they in right
now so the ones that popped out they
reapplied but what happened with this
the one that's missing the tooth under
it broke and i went into the dentist and
they're like did you have blunt force
trauma to your face
[ __ ] is that hit with a baseball bat any
time
okay miss woman if you owe anybody money
and i was like
i didn't and then i remembered that i
actually had punched myself in the face
doing a boxing class and so the nurse
left and i was like hey how do you punch
yourself in the face in a boxing class i
was doing this move where you like warm
up like this and i remember just kind of
looking over at the instructor and i
popped myself in the face
yes i'm doing the oscar de la hoya yeah
yeah you should see the other guy but
i so i did that broke the tooth then
they gave me a temporary one like he had
and i lost it like a temporary cover
one to pop in and i lost it twice so i'm
so mad at myself and it's so expensive
where are you why are you taking the
tooth out that you lose it man because
the only correct answer is
you take it out maybe when you brush
your teeth yeah that you would think
that was the plan so the tooth's not
coming back the tooth is completely gone
the tooth is done does it look like it's
coming back
oh it'll be back fully any day now
that's every night i go to bed hey emma
keep drinking your milk maybe that tooth
is going to show up again well the good
news is with my baby tooth so it's not
working
i'm gonna get a dental implant but then
the tooth got infected and it was just
like this whole thing but where i lost
it was i had been in boston and i had i
said i'm not gonna lose this [ __ ]
tooth when i travel so i put it in a
special place and then i went and uh put
the bag this bag down altoids box yeah
pretty much actually it was pretty much
an altoids bar it was like a dip
container
it was i put it in uh i put it in i
might have actually been an altoids box
it was in a and then i put in my
bathroom bag and then i put that bag
down
uh and never found it again
i know
i'm sorry i just don't want to spring
for another one the thing is is so i am
going to because i was like this is too
much because i was getting depress i was
making me depressed sure yeah so not not
missing the tooth was making me
depressed was it was so hard to get an
appointment with the dentist i was going
to and i it kept getting infected it
turns out there was too much bone in the
bone graft
so you know you're nowhere near that's
where they drop that's where they're
grossed out i lost a tooth i got a bad
grasp
how's your
i got a background extra bone yeah isn't
that gross and they were charging they
charge you for the bone
that's why sure yeah larger per ounce
it's like gold
it's it's cadaver bone they put and i
didn't know that wait what i didn't know
that i thought it was your bone they
take it no i didn't ask i'm an idiot i
didn't ask any questions so you got dead
guy bone on you apparently oh i hope
it's a human could be a dog i don't know
i don't know what's in there i didn't
this is my problem
i'll take anything at this point to be
honest but i didn't ask any questions
could you have any memories of the
person
bone that's it that's in there
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cheeseburger somebody had somebody from
the 40s or something like that that's
[ __ ] nice you're nowhere near getting
you're nowhere to the point of healing
where they're they can put them in this
because they have to put a rod in they
got to put a rod in luckily they put too
much bone in but the other bone's not
infected so i found a really good
dentist yesterday actually no yeah
yesterday and he's gonna do it in two
months so i'm in the home stretch and
i'm gonna get a temporary tooth in one
week and what are they doing for the
infection is it all cleared up
contagious
it's gonna have to burn that microphone
yeah
it's cleared up but it was just making i
was on really strong antibiotics have
you guys had dental problems before not
like that no i've never had a problem no
no no no no have you you're missing a
couple oh i'm missing teeth yeah but i
never had the bone graft yeah i was
pulling well you never fixed it no yeah
it was pull it and quit it that was it
for me where are they no front teeth
though they're right here
whoa
he's lucky he's got a lot of yeah that
covers it yeah that helps he smiles i i
from this angle
it's like the [ __ ] holland what
happened they were they were too bad
i never noticed that i've never known
you can't really say unless yeah
i do that but um two bad root canals but
the story i tell people so guys don't
say nothing is that aggressive it's
exclu i think i might have mentioned in
the podcast before maybe an old patreon
but now i'm letting it out now so
everybody keep their mouth shut um i
tell people i got hit with a lacrosse
ball
okay and that the teeth that just
eventually went bad and fell out yeah
but what really happened i just had that
[ __ ] shoddy dental
what the workout why why a lacrosse ball
i don't know how to make them sound cool
i get it maybe i should do that what
could i say i'd be like i got i was i
was saving somebody you were saving
somebody yeah i think you could even
hurricane you pulled somebody out of a
flooding uh subway car get over here and
they they were they they were i had to
pull them up and they bought me in the
mail and when you pulled them up a
little piece of their bone jumped into
your mouth and got infected that
[ __ ] there you go i still think
you could say the boxing just don't say
you punched yourself yeah say like i was
you know i'm a i'm an avid boxer that's
how i that's how i keep a good body and
stay in shape or mixed martial arts
people seem to be into that they are
that's a key word it's a buzzword yeah i
could say that yeah just say i got
punched in the face don't say who just i
got punched in the face in a boxing
class right
and i mean it was pretty bad too because
it wasn't like i even punched myself
hard like i was just going like this and
i kind of looked over and was like what
happened yeah i didn't thank you as a
big power puncher i nicked myself well i
wouldn't feel too bad about it because
it could be this is my professional
dental opinion here that's what i want
is that the tooth could have been going
anyway maybe there was something wrong
with it that's what they said they said
it was already cracked that was like i
would have been nice to know they didn't
they withheld that information that's
all esca it's gonna make money i didn't
know cause i'm from such a small town
like the dentist in my town nobody puts
an extra bone by accident okay
well they're charging you by per [ __ ]
house they
this so they when they were doing the
extra bone there they originally quoted
me at 1 400 and then while i was it was
i don't have to put the bonus put the
bone in and then while i was there crazy
like and they're like the guy is
standing over me and there's a two
dental assistants they had the uh front
desk person come in and they're like
actually it's gonna be more and they
changed it from one thousand two hundred
to i think it was like three thousand
five hundred now when you're in the
chair like ripped open and i was like
and then i was like well
what do we do and then they were like
they're like that's how much it is and i
was like what are my options like what
happens if i can't pay for it do i work
here now like how do we
do i give you bone to give someone else
like how does this have they already
started the procedure started the
procedure so what the [ __ ] are you gonna
say that's what i said you don't go back
to that dentist anymore dude no i no i
don't yeah did you give him the three
g's i i did why put it on my credit card
and this was the thing too i was like
you buy the balls what are you gonna do
they get serious yeah yeah i got you by
the gums okay by the incisors because
what are you i was like i'll find a way
to pay for it but what if you know what
if i couldn't what if i had like kids or
something they
a lot of places not mortgage a lot of
places finance it on their own yeah a
finance company that you can do right
credit card guy pops up you're
interested in this stuff all of a sudden
you know you're making [ __ ] monthly
payments to the style cafe let me ask
you this
yeah did you did they take payment right
then and there yeah like why you were in
the chat oh no no no at the end at the
end and they did apologize because i did
a vid i was posting on instagram about
it like what the [ __ ] that was weird and
then they called and we're like they're
like we don't normally do that and i was
like all right yeah well you [ __ ] what
you did yeah did they actually take the
video down no
did you tag them in it
no but i mentioned them and i mentioned
the secretary by name
[ __ ] shirley yeah [ __ ] shirley
this is the first time i've ever had any
i've never had problems like this before
have you noticed any people acting
different or being treated differently
with the missing tooth yes really
because i think everybody knows you and
all it takes is it to what the [ __ ]
when some dental work so when it first
happened this was like really it when it
first popped out my face was all swollen
i ran into like five different comics i
was like bopping around and yeah what
was up with that you had like black guys
for a little while that was when they
first well that was when the dentist and
i just he we just had enough
yeah
this was this place isn't this place is
in gramercy but they uh that's nice yeah
that's what i that's why i kept staying
there because like no it's nice it's
like in gramercy park you would think
but actually in the park
bench
just a pigeon working on you
it's i'm just [ __ ] up out of my mind
this guy seems pretty good
they i had but i had black eyes and you
know i shouldn't have done shows those
nights but i didn't know i got black
eyes from and they were like this is
unusual yeah how do you get black guys
from ari had the same thing remember
he got dental work done in colombia or
ecuador wherever the [ __ ] he was and he
came back and looking got hit by a 2x4
yeah
it's because they've got you like open
and they're doing the surgery and yeah
and it's all like the blood rushing
i didn't that i didn't even mind the the
in retrospect i looked at some pictures
i was like i should stay at home those
nights take the night off but i don't
think anybody you know is jud you know
everybody gets jammed up in those cities
which almost isn't good that people
don't like you kind of want to be the
type of person that when people see your
face all [ __ ] up they're like what is
going on
you don't want to be you don't want to
have to be in character yeah yeah
classic emma right emma walked into a
wall again everybody here we go good
they're not even blinking but when my
tooth fell out the first five comics i
saw not the ma it was i saw three uh
white guys and two black guys in the
reactions i couldn't help but do that
social sample of the three white guys i
said i was like do
my do i look weird with this and they're
like i didn't even notice it the two
black guys i saw were both like what the
[ __ ] like you got a [ __ ] oh you gotta
get it together is everything okay yeah
uh sherrod small was yelling at me he
was like go home
he's like heckling me out of here
and then i think i saw todd barry and
he's like i didn't even notice it and i
was like what's going on
oh so what is the
back story the origin story of emma
woolman i know a little bit i know small
town maine yes
can either i fee i maine can either be
like
you know waspy very nice or like so
small town super trashy or stephen
king's old car's trying to kill you yeah
he didn't get hit by a car my stepmom
was in that movie what was this big one
was it uh pet cemetery she's like a one
little lion your stepmom's in pet
cemetery yeah really
i haven't seen
i haven't seen that movie trying to make
an episode of this
[Applause]
is the is the is it a good movie or a
bad movie it's good yeah i remember it
scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid god
yeah i put eyes on it again it doesn't
really hold up right i didn't say yeah
she was in that for a little bit but you
nailed it it's most my town was a mix of
two it was 2 000 people in the winter
and then in the summer was a bunch of
like really waspy tourists and my
parents were like kind of
i would say they were like waspitourists
and then they were hippies and i moved
there my dad was a carpenter and then my
mom owned a little blueberry farm and
they met when he had to fix her floor
wow that's like the most big story ever
yeah
she was a simple blueberry gal and then
uh that's how they met that's how they
met he had to fix her floor that's what
that's what they're saying i think they
were i think they smoked a lot of pot
back in the day okay are they still
i don't know i don't know about my dad
my mom doesn't but i would like it if
she did yeah yeah take the edge off
because she's good insomnia and i
was like would you consider smoking pot
and she was like where would i even get
pot
and i didn't i got it all the maine yeah
and she's in cambridge massachusetts now
okay yeah so did you did you grew up in
this town in maine
i grew up there with your mom and dad
tell me tell me because i'm under the
divorce now yeah they're very diverse
they're divorced when i was in very
divorced it's so difficult that's the
episode title right
did you ever live on the blueberry farm
no i maybe when i was like a baby baby
but i have no memories of it i did
blueberry picking for two days okay
which is where you like it's back
breaking work i didn't i didn't
last didn't laugh i just sat down with
my friend shawn and ate the berries and
they're like
you guys are fired
i didn't live in the blueberry farm but
we lived in this house my dad built and
then my parents built the house he built
the house that's pretty classy pretty
cla geodesic dome
it's pretty cool
geodesic dome it sounds less classic
wait a minute hang on a second we got
are they are you did you grow up in a
yurt
it's a geodesic dome and then he and
then he like built this like big
extension on it he's a mat now he's a
math professor
at maine maritime that's what you live
that's
it is that shape though it's a big
geodesic gun but it's wood this is what
he's pulling up is like a glass bubble
wait you grew up in a wooden house like
that
in the
what like one of these maybe yes exactly
like that you grew up and this is what
you grew up in
yes
what yeah that's a mcdonald's play
playstation
that's [ __ ] nuts um it was nuts it
was it was very pretty though my god am
i had no idea yeah that's why they keep
rock salt on the turnpike yeah for the
listener yes it's it's half epcot half
where they keep rock salt on the
turnpike what that's
it's like a big wooden golf ball
yeah it is
a room was it one big room it was they
the way my dad had he had his office
upstairs and then he built this giant
extension onto it so when my mom moved
in she was like we gotta we gotta make
this big exciting so wait that's what he
lived in prior to your your mom getting
together he built this dome i was like
i'm going to be a lady killer
i'm going to be batting them away they
get a look at my ear
and he and he had no electricity before
my mom he was a hippie right he was
living no electricity no electricity
damn he grew up in belmont massachusetts
and then he was like [ __ ] this i want to
go just like be off the grid which now i
want to be in the big city
i want to be a yurt guy
that's [ __ ] nuts
have you guys been to maine before i've
been to i've been to biddeford maine oh
yeah
doing what uh a friend of uh mine's
family is uh
kind of you know they own a bunch of
stuff up there cool so we went there
yeah beautiful it is beautiful [ __ ]
crazy beautiful it's so pretty not a
main hot spot like that's like some
place that i you don't usually hear
people say this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah hang on it's back to the yurt all
right all right
let's not get crazy here kippy's
vacation plans i gotta eat this is
bonkos did you have your own bedroom yes
i did how about the door if you never
told us this yeah i've known you for
eight years i wouldn't drop this [ __ ] on
me now
on live podcast i didn't know when it
would even it's not i never even think
about it that should be high i'm emma i
grew up in a dome you think so yes yes
really that's what it's sane really
cause i talk about myself it's like
worse than being at home let me ask you
this do you know anybody else that grew
up in a dome no so you weren't you
weren't in a neighborhood of domes no
that would be more normal you're right
i never thought about that were you in a
neighborhood no
it was really you can't put that in a
neighborhood the neighbor does get out
of the name of the homeowner's
association
what's with the dome guys hey take your
lifestyle soccer ball and beat it buddy
kimmy how about the folks over there to
butcher box baby did you say butcher box
baby
butcher box don't get it twisted but i'm
telling you what they're serving up top
quality meat californ right to your door
absolutely delicious and fantastic yeah
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat of
your choosing nice options like 100
grass-fed and finished beef free-range
organic chicken chicky chicky probably
make a hell of a chicky parm with that
say that one more time free range
organic chicky chickies humanely raised
pork wild caught lobster tails wild
caught alaskan salmon or if you're trash
salmon
uh sugar-free bacon uh that's my wife
introduced me to sugar-free bacon and
then they started sending us the butcher
box good stuff killing it
top quality stuff there's no better
feeling knowing you can skip the grocery
store because there's a variety of
butcher box meat already waiting for you
in the freezer and listen depends on
where you're going you don't know what
you're getting all the time you know
like you don't know where that meat's
coming from nope that's been sitting in
it has been sitting in the back of the
grocery store for six weeks and they
pulled it out and it could have been in
some guy's trunk a couple of nights ago
it's on a discount rate you know you
don't know who's handling that kind of
stuff not with butcher box baby uh 100
yes so butcher boxes offering our
listeners ground beef for life what what
for a limited time employees apply hold
on a second
stop the show for a limited time butcher
box is giving
is giving new members two pounds of
listen
stop the press this is all jokes aside
for a limited time butcher box is giving
new members two pounds of free ground
brief in every order for the life of
your membership holy crap that's
butcherbox baby they treat you right
over there yeah it's like walking into
the copacabana
um table up front imagine never having
to shop for ground beef again this is
mine bliss is fan and you're getting
good ground beef too you know where it's
coming from yeah process is simple once
you're signed up uh you choose a box and
the delivery frequency they offer five
boxes four four curated box options as
well as the popular custom box you get
exactly what you want for your family to
love easy peasy ships right to ship your
order right to your door frozen at peak
frettiness freshness and packed with 100
recyclable box shipping is always free
because butcher box knows what they're
doing you enjoy great tasting high
quality meat delivered right to your
door uh like i said they sent it to us
it's fantastic i got t-bones going not
my t-bone i got my own t-bones and i'm
flipping them it's nice killing it this
is your chance to never have to shop for
uh ground beef again that's right
butcher boxes giving new members free
ground beef for life sign up at
butcherbox.com garbage get two free
pounds of ground beef
uh free in every order for the life of
your membership log on to butcherbox.com
garbage to claim this deal do it do it
man kippy i want to talk to you about
ladder ladder i want to talk to you
about insurance i want to talk to you
about innovation i want to talk to you
about turning industries upside down
that's exactly what ladder's doing
ladder pushing insurance ladder's
changing the game they are for sure um
yeah if you ever wanted life insurance
before you had to go you know listen to
some sales pitch drive to some guy's
house or some you know insurance office
in a
in like a strip mall or something not no
more you do it from your home we got
technology now what are we doing going
15 policies since then what are you
talking about meeting with these people
that that's stupid um if you want to get
life in um so you know this is what you
have to do now with ladder you can get
fast affordable term life insurance with
or without i need to get some i might be
having a stroke
uh it's 100 digital when you apply for 3
million or less in coverage no doctors
no needles no paperwork it's like to
sign and drive baby just 20 to 62. take
care of it yeah so if you're between the
ages of 20 and 60 which i know all of
you are listening by the way yeah
there's no geezers listed
uh if you need coverage and you want to
team up with a company that's redeeming
uh life insurance choose ladder do it
man um
yeah sorry one second
uh go to ladderlife.com garbage today to
see if you're instantly approved that's
ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
folks let me tell you about the good
people over there at lathe weeks late
weights yup i'm sure you guys are just
like us you like a little wine these
days you want to know what you're
talking about you want to know where
it's coming from you want a little bit
of variety you got to get in touch with
lathe weights yeah uh lathe weights uh
wine subscription is an easy way to
bring exciting new wines right to your
doorstep unbox a world of wine with easy
access to different and unexpected wine
makers from all over the globe um sounds
so classy wine subscription it does how
nice is that yeah that's nice we have a
subscription they send it to unless
here's the thing lathe weights does all
the heavy lifting for you they taste
over 40 000 wines a year but only 600
make the cut this is you so you're
getting the best of the best the cream
of the crop they're not just setting out
you know
some pinot
that they're brewing in a bathtub
somewhere they do it nice man they do it
nice and this way you know the the
coolest thing uh is each box whatever
wine they send you it includes tasty
notes food pairings the inspiration like
serving inspiration stuff like that that
i'm trying to learn as i get older i
feel like a bozo and i don't know that
story sure you know and like they they
sent us each one and now like i know i'm
learning a little bit about it i was
instead of just being like this that i
just think from you know from the moment
makes me feel like less of a bozo 100
and from the moment that that box gets
there you're going to have knowledge
about eight different wines that's off
the jump i feel like a rich guy run your
mouth at parties for the next three
weeks yeah uh subscriptions are flexible
there's no commitment to continue to
cancel online at any time
right now uh listeners you can get six
amazing bottles of wine plus two bonus
bottles two stemless wine glasses for
49.99 plus tax with free delivery of
course they're doing free delivery
because lately knows what they're doing
just text garbage to 64 000 to get this
special offer text garbage g-a-r-b-a-g-e
to 64 000 that's garbage to 64 000 terms
apply available at latheweight.com terms
do we
now back to the show my dad bought it's
like 60 acres of land so he built and
then he built this dome up on this
little hill so it's way deep in the
woods and i grew up there and then when
my parents divorced my sister lived with
my mom i lived with my dad and then i
have a half brother he lives with his
mom
so we're all separated my brother my
happy i never really talk about it my
therapist i mentioned the other day my
therapist was like i know he had a
brother
really open it up
all right hang on a second all right
your mom and dad are together
they have you they have your sister's
younger than you yeah 19 months younger
than me 19 months okay so you're like
irish twins yes me and my brother i
think about 18 months apart what is your
brother am i going to ask you guys
questions
he said the army
yeah there was right angles in my house
did what does your brother know my
brother works in finance oh yeah all
right he does alright he worked on wall
street for a long time now he does some
other stuff good for him yeah he's doing
all right not a yurt guy not a hero
my dad tries to sell that something he
still owns it he still owns it we have
to do an episode in the year well let me
tell you something this is [ __ ] nuts
because he's still he doesn't live in it
though he does he still lives in that he
lives in the house you were born in yeah
geodesic dome and then so hold on a
second that's strange
say that three times fast
it's a big giant a lot of
trick-or-treaters on halloween never not
once
kids line up for fresh deer meat other
parents didn't let their allow their
kids up that driveway
would you think you were the
like don't look at the doom like that's
where the dome people live i could see
you know what i mean like you guys were
like don't go back don't go past the
creek
people
steal your dreams or something don't
take your teeth
get a premonition
i don't know if they were they were
keeping it to themselves i never thought
i never thought it was that weird to be
honest because it was a real hit it was
like kind of like a hit yeah and you're
in his defense that's definitely not the
only one of those out there there's
probably a couple of them out there
thanks fully i appreciate that i have
100 percent she's disagreeing with you
i've never seen another one now that now
that we're not even in your town there
wasn't somebody
i there was there was this place we used
to party at that point
i thought you dome people stuck together
there was this one the family of
squirrels there was like an a-frame but
that's typical for up there so yeah yeah
yeah that's for the snow dog that's like
an idea
that we'd be cracking up in the
champagne [ __ ] yeah there was a couple
a-frames but i guess that's i don't know
i just thought it was like another
unusual shape i mean those are like
monkey bars so was there an upstairs or
was it all what like there was a level
fireplace to it he had this beautiful
there's a beautiful fireplace in the
center and then he's got an office and
then my brother's room is up there and
then he's got this like uh that's that
used to be the whole house then my mom
still breaks your balls but it looks
beautiful it's probably when you're it
does look like it's stunningly beautiful
yes
it's like pretty yeah yeah yeah of
course the views that's nicer than the
wet than his is snatch
i'm trying to give you the benefit of
doubting sorry that his is
his is more kind of like that one but it
is nice and i did this show i guess it
was about a year ago it was on true tv
it was called 30 works and they shot an
episode in the dome and that was cool
like the lighting was great but they
because it was a reality show with this
woman who sold moose poop i saw that did
you you were the one
i did yeah i knew uh that's i don't know
if i saw it through you like if you had
posted it or something i posted a couple
of times yeah that was in the dome i
watched that yeah they did it i've seen
the dome he's seen the doubt
wait they did it in your actual dome
they did a couple scenes in it because
they wanted to make it seem like me and
the woman knew each other so they were
like oh we're gonna go hang out at
emma's house
and they made it it was like i just
happened to be in maine visiting my dad
so they came in and then you know my dad
and i were like oh hey little did they
know no one just stops buying mean
because it's oh it stops no and someone
stops by that dome
you're the first people to ever come
over so i have a quick question yeah and
shoes off in the dome yeah and did you
make your own shoes we did
snow shoes off in the dome we didn't
make our own shoes but shoes were
supposed to come off yeah and where i
went to elementary school i went to this
hippie waldorf school we had to take our
shoes off what at elementary school yeah
and everyone packed their own lunch
and we had something called apple fest
and mayfest where you like everyone
would get together and like sing and
dance how many people were in this
school
oh man
like small
how many years does it take to become a
witch
in this program
do you have your bag of spells on you
right now
can you put some eye of newt in my
coffee please i wish wait a minute hold
on
back this up hold up i want to know how
many people and if i ever got the
opportunity to become a witch wouldn't
do it i don't like that stuff yeah
uh-uh that sounds like someone who's
been close to being a witch you know
what i'm saying i don't [ __ ] with the
powers anymore yeah i would be a
sorcerer if i could i could see that
because that's more positive but i don't
like that i don't like gives me the
heebie-jeebies any kind of any kind of
what about wizard would you take wizard
i'm open to wizards but i don't like
anything that conjures up the
like any kind of spirits or anything
exactly i don't like that story i don't
[ __ ] with spirits me neither because i
am like a spiritual person so i don't
want to bring any bad
no none of that stuff yeah no no no no
you [ __ ] around with that stuff your
teeth are falling out
[Laughter]
next thing you know you're living in a
dome in the side of the hill
wait
so when did your parents
split up when i was in third or fourth
grade so you and your sister who were
about the same age no this th the
stepbrother was your dad's kid from
before my half brother was my dad kids
from before you know he's older he's
older they break up why does it break
down that your sister leaves with your
mom and you stay in the dome it's so
[ __ ] up because now that i'm an adult
i'm like how why would you separate kids
but at the time it was because my sister
didn't want to go between the two
parents and she wanted to be with my mom
and then i felt bad and i've always been
like close with my dad so i was like
well then i'll just go with dad to not
make him blues out yeah and my parents
were like great which they should have
been like no yeah you know what i'm
struggling with this a little
differently totally definitely i could
see why your brother stayed with your
dad your mom really so he actually went
to his mom
yeah so none of us were in the same they
didn't want to be they got out of the
dome early they figured out it was weird
way before it took you two to make me be
like wait a minute that was [ __ ]
weird
any excuse for them to make a move out
of the dome get me out of here my sister
but she they live close by so my sister
lived like maybe like 15 20 minutes from
my dad's house yeah so i'd see her a lot
what did your mom get when she left the
dome when she left the dome you know how
an apartment she got an oval actually
kept it in the circle family
she got a farm house there's no
apartments in that town of 2000 people
you know what i mean so she got a little
farmhouse very cute that's nice very
nice and then she moved to cambridge
massachusetts i think like 15 years ago
okay
yeah i'm so so i'm i'm so sorry before
we uh move on from the dome please two
more quick dumb questions yeah anything
uh did you ever get dome in the dome
what's a dome what's that mean like did
you hook up in the dome oh my god i
don't think i did i did hook up in high
school but i don't think i ever did it
were you out in high school no i had
boyfriends
and i had like a lot and you know what i
said i was like i had this like group of
close friends and i was like i was like
you know what guys like we have to wait
until we're 18 to have sex and i made
all my friends that's pretty good i was
out in front of it yeah i was like we
have to wait and like all my friends
were supposed to do like the dome people
before us and wait and wait till 35 yeah
no one disrespects the dome yeah where
are you getting this idea and i'm like
at home
they i had the and i was like we gotta
wait till we're married have sex the big
deal and i like pushed it really hard
and now i'm retrospecting like my poor
[ __ ] friends because they were
straight because they were all like well
i kind of want to have sex and i was
like why you [ __ ]
gross
so they were like and i remember my mom
was always like well you know you might
get caught up in the heat at the moment
i was like there's no heat there's no
more trust me it's [ __ ] ice cold over
here but i used to get [ __ ] you used
to give [ __ ] you gave dome in the
dome i don't remember if i did though
because i used to smoke a [ __ ] ton of
pot
yeah i don't remember i didn't know that
was i don't know i was like a slang for
it dome i didn't know that about that
yeah
head head i didn't know about that yeah
oh
yeah
muscles
yeah that i don't know about that maybe
probably i did i was always giving
[ __ ] because i don't want to have
sex without sex but i was always high
too same thing
[Music]
so i got through college baby
so they got this nice studio over here
the lobby here is nice not a bad it's
not a bad setup yeah yeah it's all right
all right so got covered you stay with
your dad until when i stay with my dad
until
when i was in ninth grade i went away to
this high school for dyslexia kids for a
little bit and then i got kicked out
then i went back she can read get her
yeah get her out of here what was that
use a decimal i got kicked out and then
i went to the public high school in my
town and i was there for four years then
i left to go to college in boston where
was the
dyslexic school it was in
beverly massachusetts it's called
landmark did you sleep there yes okay
what'd you get kicked out for i got
kicked out i really wanted to go home i
miss my friends and so i was like i want
to be my friend so i kept trying to get
kicked out so they wouldn't let me get
you know check sure they're not [ __ ]
when she's not there
they they were like wouldn't they were
like we know you want to leave emma so
they wouldn't kick me out
so i was like fine and i pretended to i
tried to i wanted to throw myself down
some stairs but i wouldn't do it so i
was like walking down the stairs really
hard and i remember the dorm monitor was
like i know what you're doing and i was
like i don't want to be here like i'm uh
i'm a hazard to myself and just like
stomping my feet and so they're like
[ __ ] yeah so then i kind of like
flopped myself and they're like okay
emma like you can go yeah you can do it
i didn't even have a bru not one bruise
there was nothing
first guest ever you're bonkers just i
don't know a slip and fall slip and fall
to get out of dyslexia school it was
more like a quick sit it was i was kind
of like because i was too scared to i've
never broken anything and i didn't want
to leave that bed but i just wanted to
go back because
i would say high school was actually fun
like just i just i liked my group of
friends in high school yeah you know
what i mean no i got you so you went
back you moved back into the back into
the dome your mom and now you were your
mom and dad somewhat friendly no no not
at all bad news they do not like each
other but now
yeah cordial are your guys your guys
parents are together my parents are not
together okay no and i had a similar
when they were like why they like
satisfied told us and then my dad was
like hey i'm leaving does anybody want
to go with us now and everybody's like
get what no way dude yeah let me see if
i was staying in our house my dad's like
i'm going to leave sure does anybody
want to come with me it's so [ __ ]
disruptive it rocks dude i'm like all
the [ __ ] snacks are here i got sega i
ain't leaving that was part of what made
me i was such a little hustler i
remember being like who's got the best
snacks and my dad got me toaster strudel
every day but then i was in a really
overweight kid not blaming the strudel
but i wasn't sure
i was big yeah yeah struggles are all
right i love strudel wow that's pretty
classy though you were you're a strudel
family over top of a pop-tart family i
like pop-tarts better but we were a
strudel family strudel's class i mean i
love pop-tarts i'm saving all that money
on the dome what do you mean i know
that's crazy i don't know
i didn't know strudels were more classy
than pop-tarts 100
yeah i don't prefer them but it's here's
the deal classier huh the pop-tart is
better and is has stood the test of time
okay thank you i so agree with that yes
and carly and acquaintance and i had a
big debate about this because she likes
strudels more
strudels just when they hit they were
they were more expensive and they had
the allure of it was a it was a better
product than just a pop dot it actually
it's more european i feel it's got the
flake gear it's a croissant but the
putting it but you know what killed him
is you're putting the on icing on you
you can't get time for that i guess no
it's a total you think i got the because
the icing's frozen and you get heated up
you're getting and then you splats right
out yeah i love uh i just love picturing
like you as a kid seeing strudel and
being like fancy
yeah that and dunkaroo's are in the same
thing oh yeah just like like that
they're in the same class of that's a
different kind of family that's family
it throws around a couple of bucks at
the supermarket that's a good snack yeah
yes you don't want to share your [ __ ]
dunkaroose
me neither my friend margot's mom would
buy them and i couldn't pass you mom
bought them oh you would go and they
still have them you go like we'll go
over i'll go over like a barbecue they
still have dunkaroos really they're
coming back pretty strong good what
about the teddy graham i like those i
used to make cereal out of teddy graham
really blow your [ __ ] my listen
listeners out there
teddy graham cereal my mom was away at
work i was about seven i said yo i'm
gonna put two and two together god damn
son i was gonna say so you weren't like
monitored no my my single you know like
my single parent in the house i mean i
split time but my mom left she's making
doritos cereal yeah
my mom would go to work my tooth just
made me spit i just got tested i'm so
sorry uh my mom would go to work and i'd
be left to my own devices my brother or
sister would be watching me and it would
just be [ __ ] game on she called me
one time doing that and was like what in
the first she's like first of all
they're about seven bucks a box you just
you just ate two full you know [ __ ]
bowl of cereal just cost you ten dollars
too much worth of snacks you got cocky
and did it in front of her oh yeah i was
like she was a while ago i do this you
know and it just became normalized in my
head and she [ __ ] put a stop to that
i remember my parents came concerned
about my uh my my eating habits as a kid
when they saw me putting butter on a
graham cracker oh
but let me but i get it but i get it
cinnamon yeah did you heat up the butter
it was room temperature yeah oh
i've done that uh oh growing up was the
butter on the counter or was the butter
on
in the fridge or did you guys have some
sort of dry ice situation
but it's on ice
you had a fridge right yeah we had a
friend refrigerated fridge you know what
at my mom's it was in the fridge and at
my dad's was on the counter yeah he i
pegged him as a counter guy interesting
i never really thought about that and i
prefer the counter i can't stand the
[ __ ] what is it in the fridge for if you
cook with it well there's two different
so salted butter and unsalted butter
one's for cooking this chef told us this
you can the unsalted butter has to go in
the fridge and that's for cooking the
salted butter can stay out at room
temperature i had no idea about that
that's a funny thing okay i [ __ ] love
butter but i wouldn't there's no reason
for unsalted butter for me i don't cook
yeah i didn't [ __ ] stinks too it
stinks you ever have thanks you think
you're expecting butter and then you get
unsalted butter
i don't think i can notice the
difference it doesn't taste like but no
salt to it yeah
it's like [ __ ] just putting crisco on
your sandwich sorry which i've done
foley and i are very upset
all right that makes sense with your pop
with the butter on the counter all right
and then you went to college went to
college i went to simmons in boston i
had a great time at college nice yeah i
think i think that was like my favorite
time of my life i loved college really
yeah i had a really good she wasn't in
the [ __ ] dome what do you mean i
can't believe you didn't think doane was
crazy until i didn't think it until
about 33 minutes ago no i mean it's just
like it was just the house my dad built
and he was always really proud of it
okay i gotta check out the dome it's got
great these beautiful windows up top not
like not yeah kind of like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get that and he's
a math guy so he's like oh [ __ ] math
exactly
yeah yeah i get i get it i yeah i get it
it's just wild for you to be like that
was my house that was my house and i
also get it too and give you credit
because in that small town out in the
woods is one thing i mean if yeah if
that was oh if it was in this you're
totally if it was if you had one of
those in like west chester or something
right and you'd be like what the [ __ ]
people would be driving by your house to
look at the you're right yeah the kids
would get all [ __ ] up like let's drive
by the dome uh-huh see if they're
outside
that place would have got egged i was
just gonna say
i i egged my mom's house once because i
thought it was like a funny prank that
people like played on each other and i
remember i just remembered that and she
was so pissed she was like you idiot
she's like you're supposed to do that i
told her i hate your own house hey my
shout out your windows
splashy tires
was your dad a hunter or anything like
that no vegetarian
yeah hippy dippy right hippie dippies
you guys have solar power
no but he has it now yeah of course he
does and he actually eats chicken and
fish so i've been so conditioned to be
like my dad's a vegetarian who eats
chicken and fish but then i've had
enough people be like so he's not a
vegetarian vegetarian i'm like he is but
he's chicken and fish if you ask him
he's a vegetarian but he does eat
chicken and fish i'm hey listen i get it
draw your lines yeah dragon did you guys
have a well yeah the hat do you amazing
main run into the [ __ ] dome yeah
there's no what are your thoughts on
well water love it so good we found out
we thought it was trashy not really it's
better because it's purified by like
limestone and then it's yeah really does
the well ever go bad though
not at my dad's here's the thing it
probably depends where the well is sure
whether it's good or not you know what i
mean i think i think
if you have a well it has to hit this
certain standard of like it's so far
it's at a certain depth
and it's a certain purity and i think
it's naturally cleansed by the like the
minerals and the limestone i think
that's what it was something like that
sounds good checks out to me
i didn't mean i remember i'm sold i had
a buddy who's well went bad and like and
i remember over there and it was like
flushing the toilet he's like you're
using like a pole and spring i'm like
dude i'm [ __ ] leaving call me when
this [ __ ] gets fixed yeah tell me let me
know when you get that dead bird out of
here yeah until then we can hang at my
house yeah yeah we don't need to do this
all right let's get into some are you
garbage questions here also i like that
the last time i saw you didn't have this
and i think i saw you pretty recently it
wasn't like three weeks ago he's like
a caterpillar dude he changes all the
time i think i'm gonna dye my hair
blonde really i'm gonna go actually get
it done blonde so it doesn't come out
all red and rusty yeah like real blonde
where are you gonna get you what do you
think about i don't ah
you don't like it i mean i love you very
lush brown hair now true and it goes
with your beard true and when it starts
to grow out your roots start showing you
really it's a lot of upkeep it's
expensive too you got it because you got
to bleach it you want something that's
going to double bleach and then do a
whole bunch of [ __ ] from her she knows
yeah i got her person my person is great
team marie hair and lori's side she's
going to park me what would it cost to
get my hair she's expensive it's i
usually spend a couple hundred bucks on
it
yeah i'm putting it in my hair not the
[ __ ] tooth i swear to god i don't
know how many teeth they could have
but i mean maybe yeah you know what why
don't you could try you could always
change it back i mean what do you guys
think should he do it to do the blonde
are you gonna do the beard and the
eyebrows no what am i a [ __ ] psycho
bleach my eyebrows not the eyebrows but
maybe the beard i mean
i'm gonna be totally honest i would just
be scared that it would look like you
were having a crisis which i think he
may be having i mean if i i mean i bit
my tongue long enough
you look like a fugitive running from a
buffet or something
if anybody from the golden corrales you
haven't seen me yeah lots of [ __ ] no
don't do that he's changing his identity
so he can go back in like we know it's
you foley we know it's you change your
hair
all right
he's hiding from the cracker barrel
right checking back in there's a giant
picture of you in the wall like not this
guy mabo mate all right all right let's
get into it but i support you if you
think it would be a fun thing to try why
not thank you but i but i in good faith
can't say i think you necessarily should
i i'll take it with a heat of advice all
right especially with all the
information that i have in front of me
from the last couple of minutes the way
my decision don't listen to the dome so
he your dad just
yeah
i'm gonna start showing up to clubs and
that these guys are at and people are
gonna be looking down like did they say
something about the dog
you said your dad still owns the dome
but doesn't live there anymore he still
lives there my mom doesn't yeah he still
lives there
because i want to ask you what street
that was on but i don't want you to give
it to you don't give away the street
there's no street there's no street it's
probably a pet it's no street it's um
hold on did you guys have a mailbox or
you have to go to a p.o box down in town
p.o box down in town
i'm from i always try to tell people
this i'm like it is
like when my friends from high school
get when we get together and it's like
someone that i want to say like got out
i made it out of maine god i mean all we
talk about is we're just like isn't this
[ __ ] isn't it so crazy how small it
is one stop light with not three colors
one blinking red light yeah wow that's
that's very
i've never met anybody
that had a p.o box really growing up now
it's the first it was so crazy to me
when it was just so crazy to me when my
mom moved to cambridge and then i was
like oh man it's just so so different
everyone might bring people to my mom's
i'm like this is not like what i this is
not like how i grew up at all so she did
that when you were you were in still
high school she did it right out of high
school because my mom and i weren't
close then she got cancer and we weren't
i think i resented her because i was
like i think i resented both my parents
like they shouldn't have separated us
but now my mom and i are really close
people are people i you know it is what
it is
i always try to think like would i have
done the same thing in their situation
who's to say i don't know if i would
have been you probably would want to get
out of the dome too maybe i kind of like
the donkey i kind of like that i can't i
would live with my parents still if they
would have me that's awesome
i did in boston i moved back in with her
like over the years a couple times
maybe like 10 years ago yeah it's kind
of fun it's nice yeah and she said
that's enough of that
we gotta go get back to the dome
all right let's get into some questions
here
what was the name of the grocery store
that you guys went to when you were
growing up there are two grocery stores
in town so there's iga and the co-op
and i would go to both of them the co-op
was more a little bit more fancy a
little more whole foodsy
what is a
a supermarket co-op because that's kind
of a thing now supermarket co-op this
was like a real code stock in it i think
it's like everybody has to at the one in
my town it was like everybody had to
work a shift so you were shipped for
like four or five hours a month and then
you get the discounts but you could shop
there and not work there but you didn't
get the discounts how they did it a food
co-op is a grocery store owned by folks
in the community and by you if you
choose that's what it says yeah unlike
corporate chains food co-ops are
independent owned and community members
who by the commanders shop there yeah
and i think is it not for profit it
should be uh
i don't know
yeah i don't know but yeah i mean it's
it's hippie dippies it's hippie
different my mom's not working at the
[ __ ] act meeting yeah right a couple
of shifts
a couple ships to walgreens
listen if you're out there and they're
still making teddy grams i don't know
what they do try a bowl of cereal i'm
telling you it sounds delicious your
[ __ ] hair back milking cookies in a
bowl totally and i bet it's got the same
amount of sugar as so many other [ __ ]
series you know what i mean he does yeah
yeah kippy they make an official teddy
graham cereal really now
i'm a [ __ ] trendsetter guys it's
pretty good i was ahead of my time you
were they only give you the head of the
bear though you got the whole thing i
hate that the head that's [ __ ] weird
as all hell yeah kick rocks with that
that's so weird i wouldn't even do it
around other people i wouldn't eat just
the bear heads that's weird
you know what i mean that's very strange
yeah it's a little creepy for sure could
you imagine if someone was just like
breaking off the heads and eating them
there's just a guy in the factory
eating the bodies
what are we doing on a teddy bear body
i don't know ralph will take him home
uh what was your high school mascot
oh my god i don't remember
items i don't remember i'm sorry if you
google ig i mean um gsa and maine it'll
pop up gsa in maine i can kind of
picture it with gsa what is that george
stevens academy gsa private school it
was public school that was the public
school the land the
special this i almost said special at
the dyslexic school we didn't have
mascot
i mean
maybe the crosswords or something yeah
it'd be like if someone's walking the
wrong way in the fields at the games
like we want to draw attention to
ourselves give it up for the word
jumbles everybody
i joked about
i did some jokes about being at a
dyslexic school and this guy wrote the
meanest review he was like he basically
said he's like you've heard it all
before like like everyone's got jokes
about going to dyslexic school and i was
like what like who else who else
yeah there's not that many comedians who
went to this lecture right and i was
like not that i even knows that you
hacked yeah i was like i mean i don't i
don't think of myself as super original
i mean you're gonna have a go you could
might have a good time and it's not the
most profound it's not profound in any
way but i would say that particularly
yeah yeah it's not been treadable yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
do you say it was some kind of i want to
say like a rooster i remember t-bones
got it yes what is it it says the mascot
for your weird school in maine was
loneliness
oh it's stephen king it's the eagles
baby
yeah oh gsa eagles yeah yeah yeah thank
you gsa rooster yeah
it was iceberg a lot of school spirits i
was gonna say
some kind of pigeon or something it was
a weird hand there's some kind of [ __ ]
it was a rat with wings i don't know
what it was i've been in new york too
long yeah what are those rat with wings
called like an eagle did you guys have a
football team no too small too small too
small
how many people were in your graduating
class
it was i think all right i think it was
like it was definitely under 100 it was
probably like 85. wow yeah wow how big
were your guys in school 505 in the
graduation yeah yeah about 400. and
that's actually considered not big no
it's not yeah yeah but a lot of split
when i was in high school it split the
two schools so it would have it was like
they were typically like a thousand
eleven hundred twelve hundred how did
they decide who went
and there was one cop and he would be in
town on tuesdays and thursdays we didn't
even have a full-time cop really yeah
what if something happened
you'd have to call in like the sheriff
or the deputy deputy yeah like the
county then stuff yeah exactly you
called a trooper right ah what if i
wasn't a trooper that's why i have to
show up i'm not like a gun guy but if i
lived out there oh get them out of here
because like it's going to take [ __ ]
40 to 40 minutes for the gun turrets on
the dome
get to the top get to the 50 counts on
top of the dome it's also totally
different like in i remember back in
high school during hunting season i
remember over the loudspeaker the
principal being like we have to tyler
cousins like you forgot to lock up your
gun like you need to make sure your
gun's locked up he was like oh okay and
then he ran not i'm hoping i'm not being
toned up to this
like oh i think that's the show but that
was just how different it was and it was
like okay
you have to you couldn't bring the gun
into school but you could have he you
had to have like a gun there's some like
thing in the back of the truck or
whatever it is and his gun was out but
like it has to be locked up and all that
car or whatever because you want to
leave oop
did i [ __ ] i think you're losing no no
he uh how did your sound go maybe
that is fun as long as you guys can hear
oh there we go thank you so much kevin
he you want to leave right away so you
can get hunting during the day yeah yeah
yeah so it was like you can you can hey
listen you can bring your stuff right to
school just make sure it's secure right
so you can go hunting registered and
that's probably changed but so that to
me it's like i'm sure that's changed but
yeah even you know that's not because my
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy it's just a
totally different it's like it's a
different place right it's like
geographically and culturally it's way
different right and also it was a
different time i mean that was you know
whatever 15 years ago whatever you know
and i remember i had this friend from
the city and she was i forget she wasn't
in me and i forget where she was but she
was like so disgusted and she was like i
saw a dead body in the back of a truck
and i was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and i put it together it
was a deer or something it was a skinned
deer like she was like it was just some
giant you guys are driving around with
corpses in your back she was like what
in the [ __ ] like that was eight point
[ __ ] that's a good eating she probably
she had to know what like i don't know
what she thought it was she was like
what the [ __ ] there was just some kind
of i was like yeah you gotta hang it and
like bleed it out i guess
any stained glass windows in your dome
in your dome or your mom's house
oh my god
stained glass window i would have to say
no i'm gonna say no yeah okay no because
if you go up and you have a stained
glass window in your house one your
creep two your garbage
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
because i knew a couple people that had
them on their stairs growing up one win
yeah yeah that's like [ __ ] haunted
house like the little guy kind of oh get
the [ __ ] out of here with that is it a
religious thing maybe no i just think
it's it was big in i think like the 80s
or something yeah
i don't know i remember seeing it in
movies and stuff stained glass windows
creeped me the [ __ ] yeah
garbage uh
did you take your sats i took the sats a
few times what'd you get
high score didn't do so well the first
couple times
so i did it i think i did it two i did
it two three times and i ah man i
remember i got my verbal way up bombed
the math yeah bombed and i was in like
the special room tape
where it was like all my friends went in
one room and they're like why aren't you
coming to this room and i had my lie oh
i practiced it cause i was so nervous
about being like wow yeah and i was like
oh my parents arranged it they're like
emma it's in here it's in here and i was
like no i gotta go check something and
then i went to special room yeah and i
just tried like you had time
to take it yeah
like i'm still taking it right now but
also i don't know i get my results any
day guys i didn't i remember the extra
time suck because i was like i
i don't test well i was just like time
to cry is what it felt like i was just
sitting there trying to cheat so i don't
think i did that well but i did well
enough to get into college and i didn't
go did you think you broke a thousand
definitely okay no offense if someone
didn't break a thousand
eight ninety over here really seven let
me tell you something about i'm sorry oh
[ __ ]
if you the test is so [ __ ] up i
remember my parents hired me these
tutors that teach you how to take the
sat and that is what made my score yeah
yeah we did i did the same thing it's
all [ __ ] up because i literally they
literally they were able to pay for it
so they paid i didn't learn anything i
don't know just like anything on how to
take
for sure so that's not fair at all
because then it's like you're getting i
was getting tutors like every day after
school get this little idiot some info
and i did that and then you know i
remember my buddy took his like whole
thing was he was like a smart kid he was
like you know what i'm doing just take a
bunch of [ __ ] adderall and like run
and [ __ ] study really [ __ ] yeah not
even study like i'm just going to
[ __ ] i'm going to mulch through this
[ __ ] thing people talk too much yeah
dude only made it to like two questions
i kept thinking like if the train does
leave and like it just got too wrapped
up in the [ __ ] like wait but who's on
the train yeah they're like alright 30
minutes left he's like what the [ __ ]
like fly through the next like 300. i am
the train like this [ __ ] people think
when they take if you take more adderall
i do it with coffee too like the more
you take it'll make you move faster and
be smarter yeah but now the wall of
diminishing returns it only gets to a
point and then it goes okay now we're
now working against you right yeah
backtracking anybody in your family
including you
take pills dry
like can you just you can do that yeah i
can take a lot of pills dry wow wow what
does that mean i never even thought but
i do it too i take my pills in the
morning dry yeah and then like have
maybe a glass of water later i don't
think it's good i think you're supposed
to have water with pills yeah every pill
yeah because sometimes they get like
no i can just i can just knock him right
back me too like a hand i could do a
handful me too we should have a contest
i can't i can't imagine anything going
wrong there no no no no tell me get my
phone cause you gotta make a phone call
because
it's the uh it's the fish oil it's the
only one i'll lubricate that sometimes
yeah that black you got a little guy
i think socks sucks you take vitamins
uh i do but usually in powder form yeah
i always [ __ ] forget so i got a
vitamin drip the other day that felt
pretty good what do you mean you got
hooked up yeah they put you in an iv wow
this was like maybe like five months ago
feel really good feels because what it
is maybe it might be total placebo but
it hydrates you yeah no it's like super
hydration so then you're like you feel
good everything everything's cooking
yeah yeah
i like that i might want to do that you
should do it yeah damn in the city right
they got him in the city karen fian
who's a comedian and a friend of the
friend she's been on the show for
another show she's awesome she has uh
there's some place she goes that i
really like and i went with her a couple
times i think she you get like a
discount because she's a member there
nice gotcha they've got cryotherapy
yeah i want to do that you should i've
been thinking about that you should you
should do it videotape and put it on
your patreon what does it do
it it's supposed to be anti-inflammatory
yeah like it yeah like shrinks or kills
the cells or whatever like region you
know regeneration or some kind of
regenexx
but it i've done it a couple times and i
remember i didn't go to the chiropractor
for like six months because i did it
every day for five days i got a pack on
groupon wow maybe not the type of thing
you should get on group but didn't that
happen didn't they talk about shopping
on groupon trash
but didn't antonio brown the wide
receiver do that and he got burned
i think if you yeah i'm sure yeah if you
do it i'm sure there's a wrong way to do
it you got to get monitored and
someone's there with you the whole time
so you guys used to fart in doctor's
faces yeah that guy
super bowl champ
you should write those good for your
joints yeah it's supposed to be what i
hear i like all that stuff me too
what about do you think it is garbage or
have you ever
taken a lemon at the table to clean your
hands at a restaurant no
never but i totally understand you mean
taking it like out of the water
maybe or if they give it to you on a
dish or whatever yeah and just rubbed it
on my hands and squeeze it and and wash
your hands no but here's the reason i'm
not sanitary
so like you know when when colburn first
came out and i was like who these
[ __ ] idiots that have to learn how to
wash their hands that was yeah that was
you with the happy birthday
i was like oh the back too yeah yeah the
back of my hands but they never get it
they've never been like i was like i was
that you know counting like all right
so i didn't do it with a lemon but is
that usually clash classier actually
would be to remove yourself from the
table and go wash your hands like a
[ __ ] human i did the lemon thing last
night made me think of it well here's
the thing i also caught you doing the
lemon thing before
you had but i that was when i had poop
on your hand yeah i thought i thought i
might have poop on my hand he thought he
came home from he came back from the
bathroom didn't wash his hands and he
thought he might have no i did wash
but sometimes the poop smell still goes
through the soap i know exactly what
you're talking about
yeah you don't come back to the table
but it creeps you out cause you're like
it's somewhere i don't know yeah and the
lemon really does knock out the smell
and it's an antiseptic because i would
actually think the only reason i would
do it if i knew about that i didn't know
about that
so i would do that it feels a little
european when i do it i agree
and when you get to paris tell me if
they're [ __ ] taking shits and then
white cleaning their hands with lemons
you tell me i don't mean that whatever
you're trash moving on
keep it [ __ ] moving
okay sit here and listen to these lies
any longer i flossed my teeth while i
was walking on the street the other day
that's bad how often do you floss i used
to never floss yeah i used to never i
didn't always lie to the dentist see big
when the last time i floss i'm back out
all the time i don't know why i'm
bleeding like i'd always lie yeah they
know they know but she got hit with a
hockey puck
gushing blood i'm like this is first
time this happened but i just started
flossing and then because i'm thinking
about my [ __ ] teeth all the time yeah
of course now it's yeah now it's a thing
now that's the one thing i do
floss i floss every day good for you
foley yeah can we see those gums
i can't see them
they are so pink you just had that
finger in your belly button about an
hour no it was this one whatever which
is the boob i put
those are some pink gums thank you those
are classy gums yeah
keep it fresh yeah the rest of my body's
falling apart but i think you're doing
all right thank you buddy the hair
that'll turn things
you could start getting steps in what
steps step you get ten thousand steps
today i track my steps that might be
something you like you probably get
about that anyway but it's like a good
way to just start
no no i get about 10 in
i get about 10 steps
i'm sorry that's so cute that you
thought
you probably get that
you haven't done 10k this year
you ain't been out the dome that long
i mean these dome people they don't know
what's going on because just walking
onto the subway i mean just walking
between them he doesn't walk in he
doesn't he hasn't taken the subway in
two years cars parked across the street
yeah so maybe you probably get whatever
amount you get when you start tracking
it then you're like i gotta hit ten
thousand ten thousand yeah
helps okay yeah i like it you gotta you
have to have an apple watch for that
though right oh you can do it on your
phone yeah yeah i think it's only
probably what like 17 steps from the car
door to the mcdonald's door you know
what it is you just gotta do that a
bunch of 16 and a half doesn't matter
when you're skipping
it's 10 on the way in five on the way
out
from the couch to the the fridge and
then you know whatever that's it yeah
just do laps all right let's see here uh
when was the last time you slept on a
blow up mattress last time it's gonna
blow up mattress i'm gonna say
probably about a year oh man
uh it hasn't been recent but that's
because i was doing so much less
traveling because of code bit it's been
a minute okay that's good that's a good
answer it's been a minute but then when
i moved back to
when i moved back to
new york in january i got a blow up
mattress for a night
but that was dumb of me because i spent
like 120 bucks on the blow up mattress
hotel should have gotten the hotel yeah
and i got a hotel the next night oh my
god i know have you ever had the new
york scourge that is referred to
as bed bugs no never had bed bugs never
had bed bugs okay
i like it has anyone in your family ever
been involved in a class action
lawsuit i don't think so okay good
is it school bag or book bag
book bag
mini golf or putt-putt mini golf okay
putt-putt that seems a little dinner
supper
dinner
do you watch tv or look at tv watch tv
all right book bag's the only one you're
[ __ ] up really yeah would you call it
school bags really yeah i said yeah
school bag really yeah school bag huh
yeah i gotta get i don't know if book
bags trash but
i gotta take like an etiquette class i
mean my mom knew that stuff
i think what's your mom do for a living
she was a so after she did her blueberry
shop she had a swedish weaving store
swedish weaving swedish and we're not
even swedish it's so strange
swedish it's like the pattern of the
weaving and then when she moved to
cambridge she started importing and
exporting the weaving from where she was
doing it to guatemala and then selling
it at fairs and i had i had tried
writing like a show about her having a
cheese shop and i remember in one of the
pitch meetings like what is this based
off of and i was like wow space opera
swedish weaving shop and like why did
you not just say swedish weaving shop
yeah and i had spent like maybe a year
because being like cheese shop that
stuff
that's interesting does she was she does
she make blankets is that what she makes
um blankets uh table runners
i can get you guys a table run i gotta
get you get your tape swedish weaving
table rubble yeah they're pretty nice
yeah she makes some nice stuff that's
the ones that it's just a strip down the
middle strip
yep and it's like now we're in the
middle centerpiece or whatever yeah
sounds pretty nice yeah it's pretty nice
you get she's got the swedish patterns
and then there's the guatemalan patterns
this is a little bit particular to your
area because i knew that you were in a
little bit of a rural rural environment
have you ever actually gone cow tipping
no but i just there weren't a lot of
cows around really and i don't think i'd
feel bad tipping over a cow sure and
apparently from what we've heard from
previous guests it's not that easy i
wouldn't think they don't just like flop
over yeah and why put your effort into
that i mean not that i didn't put my
effort into this do we used to do uh
off-roading where you like dry get
high and drive around in puddles yeah
mud and muddy yeah
totally do that did you have a car when
you were in high school yes what did you
have
oh man my dad got me a subaru all right
that's nice yeah yeah it's nice it's all
the writing on the wall
i have to make that joke that was my
nickname that yeah he got me a subaru
this cute little green subaru i don't
know why he got it he was like it's a
good car subaru outback and a rescue dog
yeah exactly yeah yeah
that's a very it is minus you know the
stereotype uh you know the lesbian car
is a very main car it is a very very
practical they're very good
subarus are very very practical yeah
very reliable they're awesome they're
very well engineered and it is like
that's like what somebody in maine is
like yeah we're not flashy i don't care
what it is just give me right and a lot
of their hatchbacks because you're
moving a lot of stuff oh is it a
hatchback yeah all-wheel drive
yeah did he buy you a new one used one
okay but it wasn't like a hand-me-down
it wasn't a hand-me-down he was he's
very into buying used stuff because he
loves the deal he likes the value loves
the values he loves going to sam's club
because he's a mathematician and he
loves he's good with numbers yeah how
used are we talking we're talking
probably like five years used okay it's
not bad good first of all it's a pretty
legit great first card
that's what you want your uh you know
your girl in right yeah you want your
daughter in a in a second 100 someone's
driving a corvette or something right
totally yeah because i had a friend i
remember she just [ __ ] up buick and i
was like your parents must hate you i
mean it was just that [ __ ] not safe
it's a tough look did you guys get back
i assume you had bad winters bad winters
yeah what give me an average snowfall
a snowstorm what are we looking at
okay it was always exaggerated because
in the dome the wind blows up around it
so it covers the windows because it's
like the wind gets like stuck on the
thing
but it would be like three to six feet
watch crap i think yeah that's what i
remember i know
it's
crazy it is i never go back i mean i
went back for 30 works
i went back for father's day because i
hadn't seen my dad because of cobit and
other than that i just never it's such a
hike too
any family reunions
no
actually on my mom's side they have a
family reunion like once every like 10
years okay and it's huge it's in
wellesley massachusetts like what's the
venue is like a park or is it like they
were in a hall or the harvard club
i'm sorry the what so they went uh so
there's a real twist in it so here they
were holy to a part of a rewarding super
hoity toity have you ever heard of the
author and i would never have heard of
him if he wasn't like loosely related
his name is john cheever
wait yeah what oh you guys i would never
so he my mom's name is susan cheever but
she's not his daughter susan cheever but
it is the cheever so when he used to
write about the waspy new england family
hold on your mother's
maiden name is cheever yeah that's my
middle name holy [ __ ] wait you guys had
heard of john c i didn't know yeah i
don't know i mean i don't know uh his
work but i mean i just know the name
yeah [ __ ] john cheever yeah wait so
how was the what's the really she was
his granddaughter she
i don't know how she's related to it's
just just like lu i just know that when
he writes like he wrote this article
about the cheever family thanksgiving
and he always felt like an outsider and
he wasn't good enough and he didn't get
invited that was my family's
thanksgiving so growing up we would go
to my mom's for thanksgiving it'd be
really fancy like we'd have like they'd
all have cocktails then you go over to
the other house and have and everyone
would be really dressed up and like what
do you do what do you do so your mom
comes from a little bit of quiche
she did yeah yeah and then she sunk it
into that swedish weaving business
didn't really explode
absolutely
out there with the guatemalans
yeah
um
but i was exposed to that through
her that you were the classier side yeah
was at the harvard what's the harvard
club it's like if people went to harvard
they can rent the room there
like a rent you know like that's where
you'd have your family reunion sometimes
man talk about a [ __ ] twist in the
fourth quarter he's also
part of dome people let's not look at
that right and my mom left all that to
like live in the woods in maine
but then she went back to cambridge but
it's because she had cancer
and she's you know she's in cambridge
now she's in cambridge now which is
basically boston yeah this is the other
side of the river yes
basically boston it's a yeah so her
family's from cambridge massachusetts
wellesley massachusetts wellesley boston
suburbs yeah what did what did her gran
what did your mom's dad do you know he
was a banker i don't know what exactly
they all did to
but but he was some kind of banker
banking and then a lot of them are in
finance yeah yeah
wow yeah and they think you're in the
cheever family i mean i don't know if
they would claim me but my middle name
is chief you guys missing a tuesday you
went to the thanksgiving i do go to
thanksgiving john wasn't invited to
thanksgiving thanksgiving now doing
something right yeah when's the last
time you had a thanksgiving there it was
not this year because of covid i think
it was and it wasn't the year before
that it was the year before that so now
they do it every other year because
there's only a few people that have like
big enough houses to fit everybody i
hold it yeah
so you'll be going there this year i
hope so
you guys can't
[Laughter]
we got a couple from the patreon we can
do go ahead um
guys as you know when you sign up for
patreon we'll answer your garbage
questions uh it's just the best way to
do it this is from let's see
from zachary uh
have you ever been told to wait to cash
a birthday check at the end of the month
like if somebody given you a gift
and then there was like a 20 check and
they said don't cash it no but i love
that yeah yeah i love that i love that
and listen i'm good i love that yeah
i've signed yes with
me too yeah yeah i put the date oh data
i've seen i remember my mom doing that i
didn't know why like she had to give it
to my sat tutor actually absolutely she
was like hey i'm gonna make it for next
friday or something is that okay see if
this fat [ __ ] graduates
yeah i never used to get it either and
now absolutely i've done that
so i've done that before but i haven't
do you have a checkbook now no neither
do i couldn't even imagine no it's crazy
what's the credit situation bad really
not great credit cards three of them
amex no
the only place that would give me a
credit card is united for some [ __ ]
reason but i've been a loyal customer
because of the airline the airline gave
me a credit card i give them to anybody
apparently yeah and since they did that
i start now i fly only on united
[Music]
credit limit do you know roughly i think
it's like five or six thousand that's
great on each card five thousand and one
three thousand another one is that
pretty good that's good yeah oh yeah
mine's currently two hundred mine's a
thousand so i had it at that for a while
and i had to do one of those pre-paid
situations it was like i give them 500
bucks
you get the credit against that so
that's how i built my credit back up but
it's been real a little choppy recently
i just got a venmo you can get a venmo
credit card they gave me 25 or 22 hundo
or something like that so i'm cooking
now it's man but with i've been putting
the teeth stuff on the credit card too
so that's what it kind of worked for but
sometimes it's scary because i was when
i first got a credit card i was just
like
ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-choo
and then then you got to pay it that's
the way they get you yeah of course i
had one in colleges i did not i didn't
understand it at all me neither man
hmm
that's what i understood i knew i had to
pay it back i just
uh all right this is a good one this is
from tristan i haven't had a question
read yet uh
being for me we were just talking about
it's perfect you ever let the wind clean
the snow off your car after a big
snowstorm instead of brushing it off
absolutely yeah a hundred percent make a
couple of quick turns totally you give
it a little tap tap see if it's wet snow
and then depending on it like real whip
twist the back yeah and then sometimes
when you're going by people they're like
yeah they're behind yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] about you and then the snow's going
and coming and icicles and [ __ ] flying
through the water that's awesome it
feels good to be alive did you ever do
the thing where you would take fresh no
and mix it with condensed milk not with
condensed milk but we would put maple
syrup on it but condensed milk is really
good wait i've had that what are you
talking about it's like a dessert what
is the the
mixed snow with them condensed milk and
you put like a flavoring i don't know
what it's called you would go to the
main thing or like a it's like it's like
a northeast like snow thing yeah yeah
where are you from toby chicago uh i
lived there for the last 11 years but i
went to high school in massachusetts oh
okay cool
on the vermont border nice um i don't
know if that's genius or completely it's
kind of gross though because it was like
i mean it's like i remember being like
being like oh like scoop around the
yellow but it's like you're getting
close to the yellow scoop around the
yellow yeah the pig i've
i have enough information
you brush your teeth in the shower yeah
do you pee in the shower yeah do you
keep your toothbrush in the shower i do
keep your tooth in the shower
what about the sleeping situation uh do
you sleep with a fan directly on you no
but i should my apartment now has ac but
back in the day before it did i would
put it directly i hate the oscillating
okay how many pillows do you sleep with
two just a two under your head i sleep
with one or two but if i ha if i'm in a
relationship or there's like a girl
coming over like i have a girlfriend now
so i'll like pillow it up for her sure
so you don't get in the oh sorry go you
don't go pillow between your legs or
hold one or anything i wish i [ __ ]
did because i make me go to the
chiropractor less but i don't i sleep on
my side and i always jack my back up huh
is the bed in the corner of the room
so i had a bed and then
so i had a bed
i am stunned that you're this garbage i
got it really oh my god yeah i had a bed
and also like you're part of the
achievers and going to thanksgiving at
the harvard club and that can't even
pull you out that's crap that's like you
just dropped the harvard club and i'm
like nope not going to do it
it i was had every i had a lot of
opportunities to not be guard that's why
it's like nature versus nurture i do
believe in like you know a lot of things
or do you think the dome set you back
early on in the race it could have been
but even
you have to
put the time and the place in where she
grew up and the fact that okay her
father
you know was you know lived the kind of
you know i get where you're going
natural lifestyle
but he did he grew up in a family
similar my mom's in boston but he also
like was like i'm not for not for me and
then he's like i'm living off the land
see that makes you less trash too if you
come from money and decide to and go
that route that's a noble thing
for them i guess yeah yeah no
noble i think they were just kind of hot
yeah you know i got like puffins
yeah and he was like i'm trying to get
off the grid so the feds can't tax
exactly
[ __ ] blueberry farmer you know this
is 100
from the beginning and they and my mom
despite the fact that she owned a
swedish sweden store [ __ ] hates
comedy which i think is soap she's real
yeah and i'm like and i'm always like my
mom hates comedy she was breathing down
my neck and something like well what'd
your mom do i'm like yeah she had a
blueberry farm i don't know how yeah
yeah nothing that practical swedish
weaving she's an importer exporter with
guatemalan weavings and swedish
i mean i'm i'm yeah
i can draw a conclusion closing the book
my bed's on the floor now though because
all right
that's it
because i felt like someone told me it
was like an adhd thing i felt like
trapped and it didn't feel like enough
room so i dismembered the bed now it's
in the closet dismembered is a weird
what would it take for you what would it
take to pull her out kip
a buddy if she
i mean
she dropped harvard club for [ __ ]
thanksgiving that's probably one of the
most classiest thing someone said
and it i it's like i didn't even bat an
eye at it yeah i can't really see
anything
i mean if i had like two thousand
dollars in front of me
maybe that would pull her out oh i'll
take a bribe take a break yeah you're
right and she's classy and we're back
with the classes person there is yeah
yeah
if a venmo if a venmo deposit were to
hit i wouldn't yeah yeah i think i think
we would be in the payoff realm
[Laughter]
we're definitely in bribe territory
i don't have socks on right now and i
never wear socks
do your feet smell sometimes yeah yeah
that's impossible it's impossible for
them to not yeah
i was gonna actually ask if you were
wearing matching socks so it's fitting
no i don't sometimes i'll wear but
sometimes when i wear socks it doesn't
it's just i don't know i don't like it
oh sure i'm not a big underwear guy
really yeah i get that yeah it's just
too
so good i get it i'm sure the underwear
is thankful
i'm not going back in there taking the
day off boys
ladies and gentlemen emma willman emma
what do you got coming up you want the
folks out there to know any shows any
whatever lay it on us
thank you guys of course yeah you get
the calendar you got
you got the iphone the latest iphone
though it's correct it's crap it's solid
it's crazy and it's the plus and i
brought the garbage i brought the um one
of the the one of these crack the lenses
crack so i brought it to a store that
apparently wasn't iphone certified
because once it's in now it says that
the
that the lenses are not recognized
man
lenses it's just [ __ ] like all right
did you ever wear colored contacts no
okay no i didn't still garbage yeah
yeah i didn't know where i was gonna do
it
i did everything i could for you sorry i
tried
october first i'm gonna be at the robin
theater in lansing michigan look at that
and then october 2nd i'm going to be at
back alley comedy club in also in
michigan and then october 3rd i'm doing
the lincoln lodge in chicago yes those
are the road shows i love doing guys go
check her out she's a [ __ ] killer
killer on stage let me say this no bias
at all one of the funniest people one of
the best stand-up comedians out there i
feel the same way about you guys i have
so many memories back in the of you guys
back in the day it's in so many
different spaces that's why it's always
like you know
when people are talented but then also
they work for it too you know what i
mean thank you because they were just
like that it's like that cat williams
where he's like trying [ __ ] and trash it
don't work crunch it and trash it don't
you know what i'm saying and then so but
you're honestly one of the few comics
that like when you're on a show i'll
stay and watch killer kill just because
it's
pure entertainment you know what i mean
it's it's just funny
and you're always working on stuff you
always have something new you always
have a different twist on something yeah
so folks do yourself a favor if you live
in those areas go check out emma she's
absolutely amazing yeah let me know if
you think
feel free to dm me on instagram if you
think you should get his hair blonde i
mean i'm sorry i'm curious what you're
listening what you guys think
i don't know
we'll see i mean maybe a patreon goal
yeah
could be get my pubes bleach too
spice it up sorry kevin looks like jonah
hill we're going to see his pubes now
[Laughter]
give me what he got for me uh kevin ryan
comedy on all social media and then uh
guys patreon.com
itunes youtube the whole [ __ ] nine we
appreciate all the [ __ ] support i
don't care on the patreon off to patreon
if you watch it just [ __ ] all the
support has been fantastic thank you so
much what an episode gang evan thank you
so much gang we love you and we will see
you next week